[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey everybody so I'm standing backstage
at the Google clouds HQ we're literally
seconds away from kicking off the
keynote for developer
I am so excited to share our predictions
are you ready
let's do this hello everyone please
welcome Google developers vice president
Janine Banks
foreign
welcome to next 22.
I'm Janine Banks and I lead developer
products and community at Google my team
and I love empowering developers to
build Innovations for the future
which leads me to the theme of next this
year
today
meet tomorrow
to tell you a little more about how we
think about tomorrow my friends and I at
Google Cloud will share top technology
predictions for where we believe the
cloud is headed over the next three
years
each one of us will share the one
prediction We Believe will be true by
the end of 2025.
and we love to hear what predictions you
all come up with too
you can do that by responding to our
original video or creating your own
video on YouTube shoots shorts or any
other social video platform
just use the hashtag Google Cloud
predictions and tell us all about it
but before we get into all of that I
want to talk about our developer
Community for a minute I get most
excited about the incredible ideas and
new products coming from our community
as well as the opportunity we have to
help developers learn grow and build
powerful systems and engaging
experiences
Google's developer Community is
inclusive
one word cloud developers at every level
of expertise are welcome while being
challenged at the same time
and being part of Google's developer
Community creates true economic impact
because Google Cloud certified
professionals are some of the highest
paid in the industry
this same Cloud developer Community
Fosters the creators and by that I'm
talking about the students the career
switchers and anyone else hoping to
become a developer who's encouraged and
supported to bring their Creations to
life
just like we saw with our partner in
Brazil Soul code Academy and one of our
newest professional data Engineers
Patricia
take a look
[Music]
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this is why I'm excited to come to work
every single day and the potential of
what we can build together with all of
you
speaking of exciting we recently
announced a new partnership with the
Drone Racing League we built new
immersive learning experiences with DRL
that will blow your mind
you can participate in the Google Cloud
challenge where you can get Hands-On
with drl's race data and Google cloud
services
You can predict race outcomes give
performance tips to DRL Pilots to help
them smoke their competitors and learn
all at the same time
and you even get to compete for a chance
to win a trip to the season finale of
the League's World Championship
you can get started with the challenge
right now
we look forward to seeing what you'll
build next as we fly into the future of
cloud together
do you see what I did just there fly
drones okay okay
are you ready
let's go
my prediction is by the end of 2025
developers will start with with neural
inclusive design we'll see a 5x growth
in user adoption in their first two
years in production
according to the National Institutes of
Health up to 20 percent of the world's
population is neural distinct
with the other 80 being neurotypical
these two groups make up what is called
neural diversity
and neurodiversity describes the ways
people experience interpret and process
the world around them whether in school
at work or through social relationships
and here at Google we believe the world
and our workplace needs all types of
thinkers
what do you think about that Jim that's
right one in five of us here are Nero
distinct but what is Nero inclusive
design
near occlusive design is designed for
cognitive and sensory accessibility
one of the things that makes
participation in meetings accessible to
me is the raise hand function it allows
me to pause the Cadence of the meeting
to provide an opportunity to share my
thoughts
then we realized that this made meetings
better for everyone it created more
structure for everybody which enabled
visibility and broader range of ideas
so neuro inclusive design starts with
raising accessibility for neurodistinct
people like myself
everyone benefits
good design is already in your inclusive
when implemented properly as an example
When developing interactive and visual
features we need to consider how noise
vibrations or pop-ups show up in design
because it creates sensory stimulation
that leads to distraction
design principles can be made Nero
inclusive when you plan thoughtfully for
balance proportion Unity light color
space and patterns and here are some
tips for developers number one
designed with Simplicity and clarity
number two remove distractions or extra
visualizations like pop-up Windows three
avoid really bright colors are too much
of a single color
four
stick with the predictable and intuitive
user flow
five
be thoughtful about the vibe your
setting do you need music or sounds to
set the tone or is that just an extra
element that can create distraction
and finally six
stay away from pressure points requiring
a quick reaction from the users this can
add unnecessary pressure
back to you Janine
thanks Jim this upfront design
thoughtfulness is just so important how
often have any of you been pressured to
ship something but you knew you could
have improved the user experience with
just a little more time
at Google we feel that ideation user
research testing and marketing
disproportionately helped teams launch
more inclusive products faster
while these are standard practices in
software development where we made a
conscious decision to have all types of
thinkers included across these phases
our eyes open in so many new ways to be
more inclusive
for example closed captioning in Google
meet helps all of us process information
better visually it also helps people
participating in meetings where
different languages use
when you build simple clear experiences
with fewer distractions your products
will inherently Drive greater user
adoption in fact what did I say I
predict 5x more in your first two years
in production
this is because developers like us will
have built belonging directly into our
products
so that's my prediction now I'm going to
pass the mic to some of my friends here
at Google Cloud to share their
predictions thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Eric Brewer and my prediction
is that by the end of 2025 four out of
five Enterprise developers will use some
form of curated open source
now you're probably wondering what is
curated open source
curated open source is just open source
as you know it but with a layer of
accountability what I mean by that is
curated open source comes with support
for Developers
and the curator in this case will focus
on not just finding vulnerabilities but
helping to fix them too they'll update
all dependencies and track new ones
with curated open source the curators
will build in automation for testing may
even offer response-based slas
here's why this is so important for the
community
open source is everywhere
it helps power our electrical grids
Water Supplies oil pipelines it's
fundamental to all clouds
most Nations and even widely used in
proprietary software
open source is public infrastructure and
it's essential part of our everyday
lives
so now what
open source is here to stay but
everything it Powers is vulnerable
the incidents are real and they are
costly
is why governments are stepping in with
regulations like federamp and executive
orders to combat cyber security
regulations like these are super
important and show us just How Deeply
security vulnerabilities impact Our
Lives
but in fact these regulations are
exactly why we need curation
curated open source enables you to
depend on the open source beyond the as
is approach we use today
we believe in this philosophy so much
that we are already working on it
to help you build to care apps faster
we're releasing software delivery Shield
this is the fully managed security
solution to protects your software
supply chain from source to deployment
and as part of SDS we have our initial
curated open source example called
assured OSS
this service curates open source
packages used by Google and makes it
available to you our Cloud Developers
Google scan analyze and fuzz test more
than 250 Java and python packages for
security vulnerabilities on your behalf
and we'll update them as needed
so don't believe me that developers use
some form of curation how about this let
us show you what we're going doing at
Google to make this reality hi Aja hey
hair so let's actually see what the
software delivery life cycle looks like
if you use software delivery Shield to
enforce responsible use in open source
through policy
so we're going to start with Cloud
workstations a complete development
environment in the cloud
Cloud workstations is highly
customizable and the version I'm showing
today has all the tools and compilers
and everything I need including the
brand new source protect extension
actually right here you can see that
Source protect has flagged a dependency
with a known vulnerability
I can fix this right now on my
workstation before anything is ever
checked it
now Cloud workstation is going to
automatically detect those changes and
it's going to redeploy my app on my
workstations as needed this shortens my
Dev Loop and makes me more productive
so when I push my changes because I'm
happy with them Cloud build is going to
run continuous integration against our
code base
here you can see a cloud build build
report and you can see that we provide
salsa level 3 compliant build provenance
Cloud build also scans for
vulnerabilities
and here we can see a list of
vulnerabilities including details on
many of them and in some cases even the
fix that we need to make to address it
now it happens to be that the image that
Eric and I are working with today has
several external open source
dependencies for example spring boot
starter
in general pulling these directly from
the internet could pose some risk
fortunately that dependency and many
others are in the assured OSS portfolio
so that I can use a version of that
dependency that's been vetted by Google
which is what you've been telling us
about this is exactly the point you
don't have to worry about these
dependencies because they are already
vetted for you
and so now that I know that I don't have
to worry as much about these depend
Tendencies it's time to push the code to
prod so let's actually look at a
delivery pipeline
here's a cloud deploy delivery pipeline
super simple one we've just got a Dev
and a test environment and when I'm
happy with my code and depth I can
promote it to fraud and we can deploy to
gke
so while that's deploying
let's look at one last thing
here's the new gke security posture page
here I can see security concerns on both
the cluster and workload level
I can dig into any concerns if I need to
including seeing recommended actions to
take to mitigate any issues that were
identified
so that's the dev to prod tour of
software delivery Shield so you can see
how it helps you use open source
responsibly all the way from the when
you start writing code to when it's
released into production that was great
thank you Aja
we love co-creating
we just want to make sure there's an
added layer of accountability to better
support you and the apps you build
is why we believe that four out of five
Enterprise developers will use some form
of curated open source thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
first off it is so nice to see everyone
here in the room give it up for being
back in in person right
[Applause]
my name is Iman ganizada and my
prediction is that by the end of 2025 90
of security operations workflows will be
automated and managed as code
okay so secops teams are struggling to
keep up with the attackers we all know
this right there's there's too much data
complex technology environments and
there's more adversaries now more than
ever I mean every day on the news we
hear about a new 18 year old that has
breached a company right
so so let's go ahead and let's pair this
with the detection and response workflow
which is notoriously centered around
toil and it requires a linear growth in
people to keep up with the volume of
threats
but we all know we can just hire a bunch
of more people right like every ciso has
a billion dollars in their bank and you
know they're just waiting to hire 700
000 people
so this inefficient workflow has
basically created the cyber security
Talent shortage there's over 700 000
unfilled cyber jobs and these jobs
they're they're high stress they're
overloaded with toil-based work and a
lot of folks are quite frankly just
burnt out so there's just no way that
this issue is going to get solved if we
keep doing things the way that we're
doing them today
so to scale security across Cloud we're
going to make security more agile and
accessible to everyone through code
here's how
so our autonomic security operations
framework is designed to help you take
advantage of our API first approach with
Chronicle security operations and other
tools including many of those tools that
are within our new mandian portfolio
this shift in our new framework takes
traditional assembly line security
operations workflows into a codified
continuous feedback model we call
continuous detection continuous response
or cdcr for short
you can imagine it's it's kind of like
Ci CD but but for threat management
we've seen customers like BBVA and NCR
and as well as our mssp partners like
cideris use our tools to build
continuous detection response workflows
that scale across billions of alerts
and so earlier this year we actually
partnered with miter Ingenuity with
cideris and others to launch community
security Analytics
CSA is an open source repo that we
created to Foster Community
collaboration on developing security
analytics for your cloud workloads
these analytics can be deployed as code
to complement the native detection
capabilities in chronicle and other
Google Cloud tools so it's it's kind of
like having a team of devs collaborating
on your detection rules
so I'll show you how to deploy these
rules but first let's actually dive into
an example okay
let's just say that there's a user
outside of your devops team that gets
access to impersonate a highly
privileged Production Service account
that probably wouldn't be good right
so yeah so to rule 2.20 analyzes your
admin activity logs for permission
grants on service accounts
and for this next part we went ahead and
pre-recorded this because we wanted to
save time and also I don't want to have
you watch me fumble over my keys and
take down Us East or something
so first we're starting in the terminal
and we've already cloned a private repo
here
now we're going to go ahead and open up
that URL rule and we can add parameters
to fine-tune the world our needs so in
case you haven't noticed Chronicles URL
syntax is very very very simple compared
to other detection languages
now we're going to go ahead and commit
and push our changes and we already have
a GitHub action set up to Auto deploy
these rules into our Chronicle instance
and by the way Chrono can be deployed as
code and it can scale across petabytes
of data without needing infrastructure
or human involvement I mean it's it's as
Cloud native as they come
okay so we're going to Pivot into our
Chronicle instance we're going to
refresh and let's see voila okay boom so
there's our new rule and from this point
on it's going to start alerting when
this malicious activity is identified
we can also run a retro hunt which
essentially takes this Rule and it runs
it against all of our historical data in
chronicle to see if there's an alert
that we missed and we've done retro
hunts with customers that have taken
seconds or minutes that may have taken
them hours or days with their existing
tools I mean it's like it's Uber fast
we can also use Chronicle soar to create
a an automation Playbook basically to
figure out how to respond to this type
of alert
and we also have Autumn we also have
apis to automate this entire thing from
ingest to analytics to response
so the moral of the story is what
um none of us want to end up on the news
right
so so in order to make this 90
prediction a reality security analysts
are going to have to work a lot more
like devs so they can free up time to
focus on the most important threats to
their organizations so you'll need to
implement modern developer friendly
workflows like cdcr across your
detection and response practice and what
I've shown you today is how we're making
it possible for you to do so thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
hi my name is Camilia aryafar and my
prediction is by the end of 2025 AI is
going to be the primary driver for
moving to a four day work week
[Applause]
so what does this mean to you and me a
three-day weekend
well what it actually means is being
able to comfortably complete five days
worth of work in four days or even less
with efficiencies gained through AI
Enterprise use of AI alone exploded over
the past few years touching all aspects
of business one of the greatest reasons
behind this is ai's huge potential to
increase employee productivity
you have told us how excited you are to
work with Google Cloud because we make
all of the AI research AI models and ml
toolkits from Google available to you as
Enterprise grade products and solutions
like vertex AI
since its launch vertex AI has helped
data scientists shipml models faster
into production by automating routine
tasks like Model Management monitoring
and versioning
with vertex AI data scientists can now
build and train ml models five times
faster meaning increased time for
experimentation reduce custom coding and
the ability to move more ml models into
production
today with the announcement of vertex AI
Vision we are taking this a step further
and providing you with a fully managed
development environment for creating
computer vision applications
in the general keynote with a smart City
use case my colleague Jun Yang discussed
how you can use vertex AI Vision to
reduce the time required to build and
deploy computer vision applications from
weeks to hours
now let's dive into three areas that I
as a developer am most excited about
when it comes to vertex AI vision
the ability to use your own custom
models
integration with bigquery
and developing external applications
with sdks
let's see how
first in the Smart City example we used
a pre-built occupancy analytics model to
detect and count Vehicles now if I want
to do the same thing for bicycles I can
use a custom bicycle detection model in
vertex Ai and easily imported into my
computer vision application
basically if the model Works in vertex
AI then it will also work in vertex AI
vision
second I want to use the power of
bigquery to combine video annotations
with other information in my data
warehouse
by the way I can also store annotations
in the included Vision Warehouse feature
to easily search for insights across my
video
by using vertex AI Vision together with
bigquery I can correlate traffic
patterns with weather patterns or even
make a forecast with bigquery ml to
predict future traffic patterns
finally I can use the SDK to access
process with your data and annotations
and hook into a live stream of vehicle
accounts to power other applications or
dashboards
it's that simple and it can be applied
to one video stream or even hundreds of
video streams
this level of flexibility and
scalability is unique to Google cloud
and that's how we help you reduce the
development time for computer vision
applications from weeks to hours
not just with vertex AI Vision but all
of Google Cloud's AI products are built
to help you be more productive and
Delight your customers
for example using contact center Ai call
center teams can manage up to 28 more
conversations concurrently
it's a lot productive a lot more
productivity with translation Hub
localization teams can translate
documents into 135 languages in a matter
of seconds which means time save for
other efforts and a more inclusive
workplace
similarly with Google Cloud's
recommendations AI merchandising and
e-commerce teams can now Drive 40 more
customer conversions
that means a lot more happy customers
and a happy sales seem to
when you put together all of these
productivity gains powered by AI across
the organization a four day work week is
a very distinct possibility
thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Irina Farooq and my prediction is
that by the end of 2025 90 of data will
be actionable in real time using ml
I'm sure many of you are pretty
skeptical of this prediction and that's
understandable
a recent survey found that only
one-third of all companies are able to
realize tangible value from their data
and we continue to hear that many of you
are trying to fix that by taking on the
operational burden of managing data
infrastructure moving data around and
duplicating data to make it available to
the right users in the right tools
so then how do we begin to overcome
these barriers before data can be
actionable in real time using ml
since our Inception Google has been
focused on delivering highly
personalized information that is highly
trusted by billions of people around the
world
data is in our DNA
the same data infrastructure that's
allowed us to innovate is available to
you and that is why we believe we can
make this prediction a reality
take for example our customer Vodafone
as one of the world's largest
telecommunication companies Vodafone
unified all their data so that thousands
of their employees can innovate across
700 different use cases and 5 000
real-time data feeds
they now run AI development 80 percent
faster more cost effective all without
compromising governance and reliability
so then how can we help you achieve your
own data infrastructure vision
the short answer is in three parts
first you can't act on data unless you
can see it and trust it
today we're announcing automatic
cataloging of all your gcp data with
business context in dataplex
and you can integrate third-party
sources too
what this means is is that you no longer
need to spend days looking for the right
data and instead can spend time working
with it
but once you find your data how do you
know you can trust it
have you ever been in a meeting where
someone questions the validity of a
single data point and then nobody can
trust anything that's being presented
from that point onward
that's why I'm particularly excited
about the new data quality and lineage
capabilities in dataplex bringing
intelligence and automation to help you
trust your data
second you can't act on data unless you
can work with it
to innovate you've got to be able to use
the best tools for the job across all
your data
King of the best tools I'm excited about
bigquery's new support for unstructured
data
now you can be sure that you can your
bigquery skills will pay off across all
your data from structured to
semi-structured to unstructured
it is also important to be able to use
the best of Open Source tools
last year we introduced our serverless
spark offering
and today we're announcing that you can
run spark directly from bigquery with
fully integrated experience and billing
but this is still just the beginning
we have a bold vision for our spark
offering to break the Google
infrastructure magic all without forking
open source
take for example mind mouth the shuffle
service powering bigquery and dataflow
that helps deliver scale reliability and
performance that you know and love with
those services
that's coming to a spark job soon
lastly you can't act on today's data
tomorrow
we've heard from many of you that you
struggle with making real time in
context experiences a reality for your
own customers
data flow a streaming analytics service
Powers critical Google services and we
believe it can do the same for you
with dataflow you can use Apache beam to
build the unified batch in real-time
Pipelines
you can start small while having the
assurance that you can process real-time
events at extreme scale if your
application needs it
to summarize when you can see the data
trust the data and work with data as
it's collected we can see how ninety
percent of data will be actionable in
real time using ML and the incredible
Innovation that that will unleash thank
you very much
[Music]
all right
I'm Andy Goodmans and I predict that by
the end of 2025 the barriers between
transactional and analytical workloads
will disappear
traditionally data architectures have
separated these mixed workloads and for
good reason
fundamentally they're underlying
databases are built differently
transactional databases are optimized
for fast reads and rights while
analytical databases are optimized for
aggregating large data sets because
these systems are largely decoupled many
of you are struggling to piece together
different solutions to build intelligent
data-driven apps
for instance to provide personalized
recommendations for e-commerce apps need
to support both transactional and
analytical workloads on the same data
set and without negatively impacting
performance
at Google Cloud we're uniquely
positioned to solve this problem because
of how we've architected our data
platform
our transactional and analytical
databases are built on a highly scalable
disaggregated compute and storage system
and Google's high performance Global
Network allowing us to provide tightly
integrated data services
and to help you unify your data across
your apps today I'm excited to tell you
more about new capabilities we recently
announced
First Data stream for bigquery which
allows you to easily replicate data from
transactional databases into bigquery in
real time
next database migration service which
provides a one-click migration from
postgres into alloy DB for operational
Analytics
and lastly we support query Federation
with spanner Cloud SQL and bigtable
right from the bigquery console to
analyze data in transactional databases
but don't take my word for it let's see
how some of these Technologies remove
barriers for our fictitious company
symbol Bank
symbol wanted to integrate their core
banking features in their app with
Market data to provide personalized
real-time investment dashboards
the problem was their app's back end was
optimized for transactional workloads so
how do they maintain the responsiveness
of their app while adding analytical
goodness
symbol Bank chose Google Cloud's new
fully managed postgres compatible
database alloy DB offering the
capability to analyze transactional data
in real time
now migrating all their existing data
with minimal downtime felt like a big
lift for the symbol Engineers but it
turns out that database migration
service makes this simple
and I'll walk you through just how easy
it is
database migration service lets you
migrate from postgres to alloy DB with
continuous replication minimizing
downtime
once we Define where we're migrating
from and what we're moving our data into
we can see the prerequisites for the
migration directly in our in your UI
sources are defined using profiles which
contain host username and password and
you can pre-define them like I've done
here for symbols postgres instance
here we Define our destination and some
basic configuration options and then we
get to hit create
this part will take a few minutes so
I've sped up time a little bit
once it finishes a quick test to ensure
that it will all work
and then hit create and start
once the initial dump is finished we're
now in a state where we have both the
old and new database populated with our
live data continuously replicating from
altenew and that means we can do cool
stuff like testing the performance of
our new investment features against both
the existing production postgres
database and the new alloy DB database
side by side
since salary DB is fully compatible with
postgres you don't have to make any
application changes and as you can see
we're getting much better performance
out of the new adoidb backend
adoidb is four times faster for
transactional workloads and up to a
hundred times faster for analytical
queries compared to standard postgres
making it the perfect database for these
kind of hybrid workloads
we all want to act on data in real time
without the toil of infrastructure
assembly and operations we've given you
a taste of how Google cloud makes it
easier for you to build data-driven apps
on a unified platform
and this is why I predict that by the
end of 2025 the barriers between
transactional and analytical workloads
will disappear thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
my name is Amin vadat and my prediction
is by the end of 2025 over half of cloud
infrastructure decisions will be
automated based on organization's usage
patterns to meet performance and
reliability needs
at Google we believe the work we do
today with our partners will Define the
next generation of infrastructure for
the world
while some people look at infrastructure
as a commodity we see it as a source of
inspiration
this inspiration comes from delivering
capabilities not available anywhere else
and pulling in the future by operating
at a level of reliability and scale that
might otherwise seem unimaginable
our infrastructure is designed with the
scale out capability needed to support
billions of users who use services like
search Youtube Gmail and our cloud
services each and every day
we pioneered the model of entire
buildings operating as a single
Computing and storage system and with
spanner we showed how Services could run
reliably at scale across the planet
and we've experienced Network
Innovations by Google global cash B4 and
Jupiter
shortening distances across the planet
this gave us the opportunity to
reimagine what was possible from
infrastructure in terms of scale and
capability
look at the world around us the time for
disruptive innovation has never been
more profound
we're seeing incredible Demand on the
industry's infrastructure
yet simultaneous plateaus and efficiency
you and your companies continue to push
the boundaries of what infrastructure
can provide
yet the burden of picking the just right
combination of components continues to
fall on you
to address this we've engineered golden
paths from Silicon to the console
these paths combine purpose-built
infrastructure prescriptive
architectures and an ecosystem to
deliver workload optimized Ultra
reliable infrastructure
so let's talk about the Investments
we're making in infrastructure at Google
in power and performance to make all
this possible
we partnered with Intel to co-design and
build custom silicon like this little
thing
this is called an infrastructure
Processing Unit or ipu and it gives you
massive performance and scalability to
power high performance data intensive
apps
these ipus are at the heart of our new
C3 VMS
c3s include the latest generation Intel
Sapphire Rapids processor and custom
designed offload based on the ipu that
delivers 200 gigabit per second low
latency networking
I'm coupled with our new block storage
hyperdisc that can provide incredible
storage performance
now let me show you something else
from the big to the from the small to
The Big Meet the hardware behind the new
tensor Processing Unit the TPU V4
platform
it's likely the world's fastest largest
and most efficient machine learning
supercomputer
this liquid cooled board is a beast in
both Tower and performance density
you see these pipes running across it
running chilled water over the board
they're there to ensure you extract the
highest level efficiency from this
Hardware
it allows secure isolated access and is
at The Cutting Edge of services like
natural language understanding
recommender systems and image processing
the TPU makes large-scale training
workloads up to 80 faster and up to 50
cheaper compared to Alternatives when
you talk about nearly doubling
performance for half the cost you unlock
your imagination in terms of what just
might be possible
the same ipus and tpus that power your
services are the foundation that will
enable us to automate over half of cloud
infrastructure decisions in the next
couple of years
they will support the Telemetry data and
ml based analytics to proactively
recommend the best infrastructure
it will be based on an understanding of
how infrastructure balance points
correspond to Performance and
reliability for your individual
workloads
we don't think that you should have to
think about Hardware specifications
that is the last generation Cloud
thinking
you will specify a workload and will
quickly recommend configure and place
the best option for you based on your
price performance and scale needs
we know that these automated adaptive
decisions deliver lower costs more
performance and higher reliability than
any handcrafted solution
so it's my prediction that over half a
cloud infrastructure decisions will be
automated based on organization's usage
pattern correct honestly I think it's
going to be much higher than that it has
to be in order to keep up with all the
advancements you're making in technology
the burden and complexity of
infrastructure decision making you have
today will disappear through the power
of AI and ml Automation and when you
have freedom to focus on your solution
delivery the rate of innovation and
customer benefits will only accelerate
while cloud has been transformative we
are still at the early stages
we're excited to continue to make the
unimaginable possible and the possible
easy thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi my name is Taran janini and my
prediction is that by the end of 2025
three out of four developers will lead
with sustainability as their primary
development principle
for the longest time the focus was
elsewhere we needed to build it fast
build it securely build it as simply as
possible build it at the lowest cost
build it reliably well now it's also
time to build it sustainably
we can't ignore the urgency required
from all of us to meet climate targets
and while organizations are moving in
the right direction they struggle to
take action
65 percent of I.T Executives said they
want to improve their sustainability
efforts but don't know how to do it
36 percent of them said they didn't even
have the measurement Tools in place to
track sustainability progress
so how can we help them out
we can give them better data about the
environmental footprint of their
business
so today I am excited to announce that
Google Cloud carbon footprint which
helps you measure report and reduce your
Cloud carbon emissions is now generally
available
foreign
right from the cloud console you can
access the carbon footprint dashboard of
your account
the underlying methodology is quite
unique and is based on actual
measurements of the energy used by
machines in our data center
it is also the complete picture of your
emissions
not only emissions coming from
electricity production but also on-site
fossil fuel emissions and other embodied
emissions coming from data center
Hardware this is also known as Scopes 1
2 and 3.
and of course you can break down the
data by Google Cloud project Google
Cloud region and Google Cloud product
with a simple click
you can export your Cloud emissions data
to bigquery for further analysis and to
provide your sustainability teams with
the data they need to report on your
company's emissions
we also want to help you build new
applications that emit less carbon by
making the right choice at the right
time
let's say you want to deploy a new
application to the US West Coast
from a latency perspective all of these
options are very similar
without more info
you might have picked Las Vegas which
happens to have a relatively carbon
intense electricity grid
but up in Oregon you'd find a very clean
grid full of hydropower and therefore
low carbon intensity that is why it is
indicated as a low carbon region
in fact a simple choice of a of Oregon
Over Las Vegas can reduce your gross
electricity emissions of running that
app by about 80 percent
and with this move you not only saved
carbon you also saved money since a
compute engine VM is cheaper in Oregon
a move that can help you save money and
carbon is easy to make when we tested
this feature we noticed new users were
50 percent more likely to choose a low
carbon region when they saw the icon and
that can make a very big difference
so how do we make it easy to identify
more opportunities to lower your carbon
emissions and deliver those options at
scale
well active assist now shares
recommendations to remove idle resources
and their Associated emissions
actually all of the sustainability
features I just showed you today are
embedded into Google Cloud console and
documentation
they are available out of the box at no
charge and for all Developers
sustainability is too important to be
complicated
before I go here are two things to
remember
one moving to Google Cloud gives you the
efficiency gains and energy benefits to
reduce your emissions
two
when you build on the cloud tick the
region with the lowest carbon impact for
your application
because these tools are available I
believe that by 2025 three out of four
developers will lead with sustainability
as their primary development principle
thank you
pictures
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody I don't know I did jazz
hands let's play with that weird energy
though together here today let's go
good so hi my name is Richard sirroder
my prediction for you today is that by
the end of 2025 over half of all
organizations using public Cloud we're
actually going to freely switch their
primary Cloud as a result of all these
new multi-cloud capabilities available
so quick story I recently moved from the
Seattle area to San Diego after a
vacation this year with my family we
realized we needed something different
so bought a house in San Diego before I
finally sold the house in Washington and
for a weird time there I was multi-house
and that was not good but it wasn't it
wasn't my desired end state but that's
okay sometimes you're in these multi
situations while you transfer from one
state to another and that's related to
my prediction here I think in the years
ahead we're going to see companies use a
multi-cloud strategy not just as a way
to hedge their bets but there's a way to
actually switch from their first Cloud
to their next cloud
so research data shows that the majority
of companies are actually multi-cloud
today meaning they use more than one
hyperscale Cloud sounds probably pretty
familiar to most of you I'm personally
talking to more and more companies
though they're using multi-cloud
Technologies as a way not to shift their
just their workloads but their mind
share to the different Cloud as well so
let's see what that Journey might look
like what would that look like it's
looking like three different steps we'll
do some live demos what can go wrong so
first that first part of the journey is
how do we meet you where you are today
with what you got you probably use
another Cloud that's totally cool
nobody's perfect but here at Google
Cloud we've made some unique investments
in a multi-cloud management plane that
works with your compute and your data
even if it's on other clouds so in this
first step you're starting to use Google
Cloud but you want to incorporate
existing investments in other ones so
consistency matters a ton here and
anthos plays a huge part let's see how
so first off if you'll see here I
actually have an eks cluster I built and
I've actually attached this to the
anthos control plane from here I can
manage the cluster I can view workloads
I can deploy things I can troubleshoot I
can apply common policies and even with
our recent partnership and collaboration
with the cross-plane project I can
actually create and manage gke clusters
AKs clusters eks clusters provision and
manage them all the same way from Google
Cloud which is pretty cool
now what do you do with your data we
talked about compute if I think about my
data how do I analyze all this we know
that data transfer costs are real
consolidation isn't always the right
option so for financial strategic or
even policy reasons your organization
might need data in different clouds it's
okay
so with bigquery Omni iacate can
actually have my data Lake in Amazon S3
or here in my Azure storage account and
I don't have to move the data to
actually run my queries against it in
bigquery I can actually analyze it where
it resides without moving the data so
this is one of many Google cloud
services that actually work wherever you
are whether they run across clouds or
actually integrate with the different
clouds it's a big deal so that's a
starter phase right I'm building skills
I'm moving you know kind of comfort in
this new home I have but I haven't moved
really anything so some of you might
think this is where you stop right
multi-cloud is just to use a bunch of
clouds but I don't think so I think many
are going a step further so in the
second stage you start upgrading your
Tech where it is and growing your
adoption of that secondary cloud
so step two as I start using Google
cloud services let's say things like gke
which are awesome I want to use it even
more and more so I might introduce
things like
amp those clusters to Azure and AWS is
it the gke API and gke software running
across clouds which is amazing and just
now we just shipped the capability where
I can even upgrade those clusters in
place on another cloud from the Google
Cloud console that's awesome I don't
have to jump all over the place to run
all my infrastructure
now here you might also start creating a
multi-cloud mesh and say look I want to
actually maintain services that run
across clusters in different clouds in
this particular mesh my web app is
spread across gke eks clusters all of
these different places I'm actually able
to manage those services and see them
and connect them wherever they are
but let's talk about data at this point
in the game you might use our great
service data stream to redirect your
existing Aurora cluster in AWS from
redshift maybe you want to steer it to
bigquery instead and I actually built a
stream that connects from my Aurora
database and feeds the data in real time
to bigquery pretty awesome stuff so use
data stream to move data around as well
so that's cool so for some multi-cloud
is a bit of a phase it's not a permanent
State you're not trying to get there
your final stage could be a full-on
migration to your new primary cloud
so once you've invested in Google Cloud
you might start taking advantage of
really awesome stuff like gke autopilot
this is a fully managed kubernetes
environment where we are running the
whole thing you don't manage clusters
you just deal with your workloads it's
awesome and exclusive to Google Cloud
now what's really cool is you may also
continue to use anthos on Google Cloud
to manage all of your fleets of gke
clusters at all of our regions around
the world I'm showing you some new
dashboards here that are coming out and
this actually actually lets me manage
not just my gke clusters but I'm
managing on-prem bare metal VMware Edge
doesn't matter I'm getting a view of my
entire fleet and managing that so now
you get things like bigquery for
analytics you're in Google Cloud spanner
for distributed data AIML for amazing
insights all these unique developer
tools and more so look if you forget
everything else that I've talked about
here today remember that Google cloud
has a really unique management plane
that meets you where you are but
honestly takes you further
so this is why I believe over half of
companies using public Cloud today will
freely switch their primary provider in
the coming years as a result of all
these great multi-clack capabilities
thanks a lot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
and my prediction is that by the end of
2025 over half of all business
applications will be built by users who
do not identify as professional
developers today
one of the most interesting
opportunities as organizations evolve is
that we will continue to see more
development work in the Enterprise taken
up by teams and individuals outside of
central I.T
the adoption of no Code and low code
tools will unlock this potential by
making the development process easier
for more users
how many times have you been asked to do
something but you had to say no because
your roadmap or feature request list
were already way too long
well with these tools those business
users you had to say no to can instead
create apps and workflow automations
themselves with no programming skills
required
these no Code and low code apps will be
built collaboratively with developers
like you who will provide the guard
rails to keep the business secure while
enabling business users to deliver their
own Solutions
and I'm not alone in thinking this
prediction will come true
leading Tech analyst Gardener forecasts
that by 2025 70 of new applications
developed by organizations will use low
code or no code Technologies that's up
from less than 25 percent in 2020.
organizations are getting ready for this
change and our customers are already
moving in this direction
Globe Telecom a major Telco out of the
Philippines reduced targeted business
process turnaround time by 80 percent
through experiences built by their
citizen Developers
and now it's demo time let me show you
how Google workspaces app sheet is
making all this possible today
and in the future
now I'm going to be Anne gray a business
analyst trying to help my team save time
managing request approvals currently the
process is manual and disorganized
spread across ad hoc emails and chat
messages
so to fix that first I'm going to build
a no code request approval app and then
I'll show you how my team and I can use
this app to efficiently manage our
development workflow our approval
workflow
with app sheet I have a single place to
store my data and build my apps
I can also connect to other easy to use
data sources like sheets or with the
help of it I could connect to Cloud DBS
let me show you the solution that I
could build as a business user
here's my database appsheet helps me
structure my data and prep it for app
building
when I'm ready I can create a new
application with a single click
this creates a prototype app that will
be usable on any desktop or mobile
device
after some customization
here's what I've built I have a new
request view for users to make requests
and an approval view for approvers to do
their thing
each of these views is available to me
in mobile apps and desktop apps by
default and I can also configure them to
show up in Gmail and chat meeting my
users where they are
here is my Google chat app
with this my users can make requests
directly from their team chat space and
it's reusing the same request view I
configured earlier
here's my automation that will send the
approval view to the approvers in email
when I'm happy with my app I can share
it with my users and I can add it to my
chat spaces
throughout this whole process everything
I created is controlled by governing
policies set by the company's workspace
admin for example here's what happens if
I try to share the app outside of my
domain
app sheet blocks me and keeps company
data secure
this allows it to do two things one keep
a clear line of sight on all apps so
they can deprecate update and retire
them when necessary and two restrict
access to only those users who need it
now let me show you how my colleague
Jeffrey and I can use this app to manage
our request and approval workflow
I'll be Jeffrey now I'm on Anne's team
and I have a request to make let me ask
and how to use her new app
she's added the bot to the space
and now I can quickly submit my
reimbursement request
okay now will be and again
I got this email for Jeffrey's request I
can review and approve it directly from
here
and if I have a pile of requests to
review I don't have to click through
individual emails I can pop into the app
and see everything in one place
this app is accessible to all the users
requesters and approvers with simple
sheets like Expressions it's configured
so the requesters see only their own
requests and approvers see all the
information that they need
you saw just how easy we are making it
for non-technical users to create
business applications that meet their
immediate needs with no Code and low
code you and your business users now
have more tools to work with
this is why I believe that over half of
all business apps will be built by users
who don't identify as professional
developers today
thank you
well folks that's a wrap on our
predictions
we're excited about the conversations
this will start and continue with all of
you remember if you want to share your
own prediction use the hashtag
googlecloudpredictions to tell us all
about it we can't wait to hear from you
thank you for your continued inspiration
and for partnering with us to build
what's next
so are you ready
enjoy the rest of the show thank you
everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]